aujourd'hui sur stade science les chats
prennent le pouvoir
bonjour et bienvenue pour ce soft
science aujourd'hui consacré à
l'évolution de nos amis à quatre pattes
les chats d'où viennent les chats c'est
bien connu les chats aiment le lait donc
ils doivent venir de la voie lactée mais
c'est incroyable ça 15 secondes de vidéo
étaient déjà en train de dire n'importe
quoi
les chats sont des mammifères de la
famille des félidés plus couramment
appelée rif félins les félins ont hérité
de leur ancêtre commun de la capacité de
rétracter leurs griffes ce que les
autres mammifères ne savent pas faire
cette famille serait apparu en asie il
ya 11 millions d'années environ et ce
serait très rapidement diversifié
répandue à travers le monde
les espèces fossiles de fela sont
nombreuses mais aucune égalant
célébrités le mondialement réputé tigre
à dents de sabre nord-américains le
smilodon sa popularité le smilodon la
doit à ces noms gagner bien sûr mais
aussi aux comics au cinéma et aux jeux
vidéo mais des châteaux né à dents de
sabre
il y en avait aussi en france
il s'agit de macaye rodius un très
proche parent de smilodon et de hosni
lui ce qui n'appartient pas au félin
mais une autre famille d'ophélie forme
nommée nîmes ravi d donc pour résumer si
mac et rodius et smilodon cent des
fellahs alors est-ce pilule est un hymne
ravages enfin bref l'un et l'autre sens
mais ils ne sont pas proches parents ça
veut donc dire que les dents de sabre
sont apparus deux fois indépendamment
par un phénomène qu'on appelle la
convergence les dents de sabre sont même
tellement convergentes qu'elle existe
aussi chez d'autres animaux comme
certains marsupiaux carnassiers
d'amérique du sud dignement représentée
par ti lagos 1000 us à oui on a du mal à
envisager en voyant ce gros matou qu'il
est en fait plus proche des gentils
koala ou des mignons petits kangourous
que n'importe quelle fin
et si avoir des dents de sabre est aussi
répandue c'est que ça doit être bien
pratique mais pourquoi ça c'est la
grande question tu sais que j'adore te
prendre pour un idiot d'habitude mais il
me semble quand même assez évident que
ça ne devait pas servir à tricoter une
dont tu veux que ça sert à quoi à part
mordre belles théories regardons-y d'un
peu plus près regarde le crâne de
smilodon même avec la gueule ouverte
il ne pouvait rien faire glisser entre
ses crocs et encore moins mordre à moins
qu'il est d'ouvrir la bouche d'une façon
assez dramatique
ce qui donnerait tout de même un
résultat assez improbable tu m'accordera
mais pas impossible si on regarde dans
la nature actuelle les hippopotames par
exemple et quelques autres mammifères
sont capables d'oublier règles on prend
certes mais c'est presque toujours pour
impressionner des rivaux sexuelle ou
faire de l'esbrouffe sait jamais pour
mordre
c'est vrai que même s'il pouvait
techniquement mort ça veut pas dire
qu'ils aient et oui d'autant qu'il
aurait dangereusement risques et
l'intégrité de ses crocs en tentant de
maintenir sa prise sur une proie en
train de se débattre
et cela pose de vrais soucis pour les
reconstitutions dans le reportage de la
bbc sur la terre des monstres disparu la
scène de mise à mort du gibier illustre
bien le problème
les smilodon s'y mettent à plusieurs
pour tenir la proie afin que l'un
d'entre eux puisse lui asséner le coup
fatal sans risque pour ces gentils que
nate a un comportement pour le moins
inédit cette scène illustre aussi très
bien le problème qui vient avec la
morsure chez les dents de sabre en
l'illustrant pas justement en effet les
réalisateurs ont visiblement préféré
éluder la question de la morsure en
choisissant de ne pas la montrer
national geographic quant à eux ont
choisi de mettre les pieds dans le plat
et au moment de mordre up les dents de
smilodon se redresse et font saillie en
dehors de la bouche on revoit cette
autre action au ralenti très cher ami
donc voilà je n'ai aucune dent contre la
théorie de larmes terrible mais elle a
du plomb dans l aile et qu'est ce que tu
proposes de nous pencher sur le principe
d' actualise mme voyance il existe
aujourd'hui des animaux à dents de sabre
n'importe quoi les félins d'aujourd'hui
n'ont pas de dents de sabre à les félins
certes non mais certains ruminants oui
comme le porte muscles ou encore le cep
et bien sûr les morts et attend en avril
ce n'est pas carnivore il mange de
l'herbe et du poisson rome et oublier un
peu le régime alimentaire de seconde
chez ces espèces là les mâles porte des
canines hypertrophié qui leur servent à
se battre entre eux et aussi à séduire
les femelles
je vois pas comment ça pourrait séduire
une semelle des canines de vampires de
cette taille
bah quoi tu ne t'es jamais laissé
séduire par
beau vampire a dit pas n'importe quoi et
continue ce qu'il y à de séduisants pour
une femelle c'est que ces organes
hypertrophié et inutiles sont une sorte
d'indicateur de santé un mal qui
parvient à se nourrir correctement et à
survivre malgré cette tare doit être un
chasseur hors pair un tacticien de génie
un prédateur redoutable et respecté ou
comment je les verrai comment je vais
l'enlever choix que de combattre la pire
on sait exactement comment boîtes de
nuit quand un garçon dense toute la nuit
comme un dieu
il semble être un bien meilleur coût que
le geek du coin donc pour résumer grandi
dans égale gros potentiel pour l'avenir
oui tellement que des dents de sabre il
y en a eu partout chez les reptiles
mamma mia par exemple chez le petit
insectivore adams havre pro no piot et
même chez des animaux qui n'étaient pas
carnivores facile vata terium qui devait
vaguement ressembler à un rhinocéros
toute ressemblance serait pure
coïncidence et hôpitaux mais rixe dont
la fin du crâne à cette méfiance n'avait
d'égal que sa docilité de petits
ruminants
en fait en y réfléchissant bien les
défenses d'éléphants deux sangliers et
de narval sondés d'en modifier qui ont
évolué selon le même principe
même si elles ne sont pas tout à fait en
dents de sabre mais il fait quoi les lic
le hic commença pays qu il ya toujours
un hic n'y a pas de bombe à lui que
c'est que si les dents de sabre servait
vraiment à la parade nuptiale
alors il n'y a que les mâles qui aurait
dû en avoir comme c'est le cas chez les
petits ruminants actuelle et je parie
que les semis le dont les garçons et les
filles étaient aussi bien pourvues de ce
point de vue pour autant qu'on sache je
dois bien admettre que oui
donc retour à la case départ la boucle
est bouclée bon ben faudrait voir à pas
trop s'éloigner du sujet mais revenons à
nos châteaux comme nos amis les chiens
les chats ont été domestiqués à partir
d'une espèce sauvage le loup canis lupus
pour les chiens et de chats sauvages
felis silvestris pour les chats par
conséquent votre chat c'est un fait
lisse et votre chien c'est un lupus
contrairement à ce que l'on croit
souvent les chats n'ont pas été
domestiqués en egypte car les plus
anciennes traces archéologiques
deux chalets sont ils que de trois mille
six cents ans par contre on a retrouvé
des preuves archéologiques de la
domestication des chats remontant à 9000
ans environ à chypre et en israël
et on pense donc que les chats auraient
été domestiqués dans cette région là où
d'ailleurs sonné l'agriculture ainsi que
les premières grandes agglomérations
telles que jéricho les chats auraient
donc été domestiqué il ya dix mille ans
en tant que bon nombre d'animaux de
basse cour
tandis qu on a des indices de la
domestication du chien remontant à plus
de trente mille ans
pourquoi une telle différence est ce que
ce serait un complot des chiens contre
licha non je ne crois pas je crois que
c'est tout simplement parce que les
chats n'ont aucun intérêt
bah quoi tu vas pas dire le contraire
les chats n'apportent aucun bénéfice
évident au foyer qui les accueillent
il ne faut que pioncer et une douleur de
rien de leur journée ils dépensent leur
pognon baby foot ils passent leur temps
à fumer des pétards et à grimper au
plafond
la question est dans ce cas pourquoi les
oreilles tant domestiques et les excuses
des chats chassant les souris est bien
mignonne mais faut pas pousser
les chiens sont pas plus maladroit que
les chats pour chasser les souris plus
léché yz à la chasse il a été montré que
grâce à eux les chassèrent bushmen sont
capables de rapporter jusqu'à 80% de
gibier en plus que quand ils chassent
son chien la domestication du chien par
homo sapiens ne serait d'ailleurs pas
tout à fait étrangère à l' avantage
décisif qu'il a pris sur l'homme de
néandertal qui lui n'avait pas d'animaux
domestiques pour l'aider à chasser les
chats eux n'ont fait qu'apporter de
nouvelles maladies comme la très
redoutée toxoplasmose et leurs yeux
allergies malgré ça les chats ont su se
faire accepter auprès de nous et se
faire entretenir aux frais de la
princesse et fait maintenant mais
attends je crois que j'ai compris ça y
est tout est clair en fait ce sont les
chats qui nous ont domestiqué
tout s'explique
6 millions si le ronronnement nous
attendrissent autant mais c'est parce
que c'est le meilleur moyen pour eux
d'obtenir ce qu'ils veulent de nous sans
le ronron et leur charme finale humanité
se rendra vite compte de la supercherie
ceci était un message de prévention du
cc c'est le comité contre les chats bref
l'évolution des chats nous montre que la
domestication n'est pas ça phénomène à
sens unique mais bien une relation dont
l'influencé réciproque entre l'homme et
son compagnon
les jeunes ne sont pas indispensables on
les aime bien quand même
et étant qu'ils sauront se faire aimer
notre évolution est la leur continuerons
d'avancer de conserve
pour en savoir plus sur ces sujets nous
vous conseillons les nombreux liens qui
sont dans la description et notamment
les articles consacrés à deux
mystification sur le blog francophone
spff stuff and banking
merci à tous